♪♪
>> Jessica: A TEENAGE GIRL THAT
GOT SHOT IN THE LEG WHILE DOING
HER HOMEWORK BLAMES ITS ON ERIC
ADAMS.
SHE WAS DOING HER HOMEWORK WHEN
A MAN FIRED A BARRAGE OF
BULLETS.
SHE SAID THIS ABOUT MAYOR ADAMS.
IT'S CRAZY HOW HE THINKS JUST
GETTING HOMELESS PEOPLE OFF THE
SUBWAY WILL DO ANYTHING TO HELP
THE CRIME RATE.
IT'S HARD.
THERE'S NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO TO
GET RID OF THESE PROBLEMS.
IT'S TERRIBLE THAT WE SAY WE CAN
EXPECT IT.
THAT STORY COMES AMID OTHER
EXAMPLES OF CRIME.
TELLING VIDEO SHOWS THE KNOCKOUT
PUNCH THAT LED TO A 61-YEAR-OLD
MAN IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
POLICE ARE LOOKING FOR TWO
SUSPECTS.
ANOTHER BRUTAL VIDEO FROM
PHOENIX, ARIZONA SHOWS A WOMAN
ATTACKED WHILE WORKING AT A
WIRELESS STORE THAT MAN WAS
ARRESTED AND SHE'S RECOVERING
FROM HER INJURIES.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE A LOT.
THE RANDOMNESS:WHAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW FEELS INSUR MOUNTABLE.
>> Will: THE VIDEO SHOWS THE MAN
DIED.
IT'S AWFUL.
RANDOMNESS IS SOMETHING GOOD TO
FOCUS ON.
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THE
COMPLETE DETERIORATION IN
PEOPLE'S QUALITY OF LIFE.
THE VICTIMS ARE NOT THE PEOPLE
WE SEE ON THE VIDEO.
THE VICTIMS WALK AROUND IN FEAR.
THE ONE THING THAT YOU CANNOT DO
IS MESS WITH PEOPLE'S QUALITY OF
LIFE.
WE JUST DID ONE OF THEM.
WE TALKED ABOUT ECONOMY.
ALL WE TALKED ABOUT IS GASOLINE
PRICES AND THE PRICE OF
EVERYTHING RISING.
WE CONTINUE TO CONVERSATION.
QUALITY OF LIFE.
CRIME.
YOU CAN'T -- KIDS, DON'T MISS
WITH PEOPLE'S KIDS.
YOU SAW THAT IN LOUDOUN COUNTY.
DON'T USE TRANS PHILOSOPHY TO
KIDS.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT THAT.
DON'T MAKE PEOPLE FEAR FOR THEIR
LIFE.
YOU NEED EVIDENCE OF IT?
LOOK AT BOUDIN'S RECALL IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
EVEN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AS LIBERAL AS IT GETS.
60% SAID I DON'T WANT TO WALK
AROUND IN FEAR IN THE MIDDLE OF
A TOILET, AND OPEN THEIR DRUG
MARKET.
DON'T MESS WITH PEOPLE'S QUALITY
OF LIFE.
>> Jessica: AND ON THE CHESA
BOUDIN FRONT, SOUNDS LIKE WE
COULD GET A RECALL FOR GASCON.
YOU THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'LL SEE ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
>> Jeanine: I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY QUESTION.
WILL, YOU PUT IT ELOQUENTLY.
PEOPLE ARE FEARFUL.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T THINK THEY'LL
GET HIT BY SOMEONE, WHO KNOWS
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF THERE'S A
GUN FIGHT IN YOU'RE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
BUT I THINK THAT THE CHESA
BOUDIN RECALL AND THE FUTURE
RECALL IN L.A. IS AN INDICATION
THAT PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID.
LET'S MOVE IT TO RIGHT WHERE
WE'RE -- THE TOPIC.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ERIC ADAMS
RIGHT NOW.
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY.
A POLICE CAPTAIN WAS ELECTED
BECAUSE EVERYBODY THOUGHT HE
WOULD TAKE CARE OF CRIME.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE'S GOOD
AT IS BEING PART OF THE NIGHT
LIFE IN NEW YORK CITY.
I'VE GONE TO SEVERAL BLACK TIE
THINGS IN NEW YORK CITY.
EVERYONE I'VE GONE TO HE IS
THERE DAPPERED UP AND READY TO
MAKE A SPEECH AND HOW GREAT
NEW YORK IS.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM IN
ANOTHER HOT SUIT WITH ANOTHER
HOT TIE.
I WHAT -- I WANT TO SEE HIM WITH
HIS SLEEVES ROLLED UP.
I WANT TO SEE HIM AT EVERY CRIME
SCENE AND CALL OUT ANDREA
STEWART'S COUSINS THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE BAIL LAW IN NEW YORK
AND GOVERNOR HOCHUL.
I WANT HIM WITH A SIGN WITH ALL
THREE.
EVERY TIME THERE'S A CRIME,
MAYOR ADAMS, IF YOU GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT VICTIMS, I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR YOU TALK.
START WALKING THE WALK.
>> Dagen: I'M WITH HER.
>> Will: WOW.
>> Dagen: YOU BROUGHT UP THE
REAL HOUSE WIVES.
YOU BROUGHT UP THE REAL HOUSE
WIVES.
HE'S RUBBING ELBOWS WITH TWO
FROM NEW JERSEY.
THE LEAST HE COULD DO IS HANG
OUT WITH PEOPLE THAT LIVE HERE
IN NEW YORK CITY.
I LIVED NOT FAR FROM HERE.
SPEAKING OF NOT FIGHTING CRIME,
NOT ENFORCING THE LAW, THERE WAS
A SERIAL STABBER TOWN THE STREET
FROM HERE.
HE WAS RELEASED ON BAIL BECAUSE
BRAGG'S OFFERS DIDN'T FILE THE
INDICTMENT FAST ENOUGH.
IT'S HAPPENING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN IN THESE AREAS.
THE LIBERAL LEADERS ARE
GOVERNING CITIES WHERE HARD
WORKING TAX PAYING PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO LIVE IN A DANGEROUS
VIOLENT FILTHY EXPENSIVE HELL
HOLE.
WHETHER IT'S SAN FRANCISCO OR
HERE.
THE ONLY WAY THIS CHANGES AND
I'LL POINT TO DANIEL ENRIQUEZ
SHOT DEAD, GOLDMAN SACHS
EMPLOYEE.
TO HAVE THESE LARGE CORPORATIONS
STAND UP AND SAY WE ARE LEAVING.
YOUR TAX BASE IS DISAPPEARING.
WHEN THE MONEY NOT ONLY TALKS,
BUT WALKS, THEN THEY START DOING
SOMETHING.
STOP INVITING MAJOR ADAMS TO ALL
OF THESE GLITTERY OPENINGS.
>> Jessica: OPENINGS?
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH WILL.
76% OF NEW YORKERS ARE IN FEAR
THAT THEY WILL BE A VICTIM OF A
VIOLENT CRIME.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE SAFETY, YOU
HAVE NOTHING.
LIBERALS HAVE TAKEN ON THIS NEW
ROLE SAYING WE WANT TO REIMAGINE
EVERYTHING.
GENDERS, FAMILIES.
NO CASH BAIL, SENTENCING REFORM.
WE'VE SEEN THE CONSEQUENCES OF
REIMAGINING LAW ENFORCEMENTS.
OUR CITIES ARE UNSAFE.
WE'RE LETTING VIOLENT CRIMINALS
OUT OF JAIL AND NOT HOLDING THEM
ON BOND.
PEOPLE GET HURT.
THE PROBLEM WITH LIBERALS IS, IF
YOUR POLICIES DON'T WORKING
CHANGE IT, JOE BIDEN.
CHANGE YOUR POLICIES WHEN YOU
HURT PEOPLE.
WHAT IS AMAZING, THEY'VE SIT
BACK AND ARE TIED TO THE LIBERAL
POLICY AS OPPOSED TO DOING WHAT
IS B